okay today I'm going to talk to you
about chromatography
so all chromatography is is a way of
separating substances which are in a
mixture using some chromatography paper
so I'm going to show you an example of
how the experiment works and then how to
interpret the results as well so let's
imagine that we have a particular food
dye and it's the mystery about what it
contains we don't know what's in it what
we can do is we can use chromatography
to try and find which dyes are in that
particular food dye so first of all we
get a piece of chromatography paper and
near the bottom maybe about a centimeter
so up from the bottom we do a line
across in pencil now it's important we
use pencil for this line because
otherwise if it was ink the ink would
separate during the experiment so then
what we do is we put our mystery sample
on the line so this is our food color in
our food dye that we don't know the
identity of what we then do is take
three known food dyes and put them all
there as well so these are all different
food coloring agents this is the one we
don't know the identity of what we do
next is we put this chromatography paper
within a beaker containing a solvent so
all the solvent is is a liquid that is
going to soak through the chromatography
paper separating each of the samples
please notice how I've put the bottom of
the paper into the solvent but the dots
themselves and this line is above that
layer of solvent so what we should find
is as the solvent soaked through
it separates each of the different
samples and here's what a chromatogram
all the chromatogram is that the results
from a chromatography experiment
here's what a chromatogram might look a
little bit like so let me explain what's
happening here so what's happened is the
solvent has soaked through the
chromatography paper taking with it the
mixture and some of these different some
of these different dyes have separated
out this one only contained one type of
guy whereas this will contain two what
you can do is by comparing our unknown
sample with the other samples we can see
our unknown sample matches up with B
meaning our unknown sample is coloring
dye B so that's how we can use
chromatography to and to discover what
is in an unknown sample now what we can
also do is this near the top of the
chromatography paper we have something
called a solvent front so all that is is
we can see that's just how far the
solvent has soaked through and what we
can do is we can use this solvent front
to find something called the RF value
now all that RF value is is it's a
particular number which corresponds to
to a particular dye it's a little bit
like a fingerprint so by finding this
value will be able to say that for
example if a will have a particular
value it will always have that
particular RF value I'll show you how to
calculate an RF value so what you need
is you need first of all a ruler now the
calculation that we're going to be let's
say we're finding the RF value of this
orange dot here we need to do the
distance traveled by the solvent so I
traveled by the substance by the
substance divided by the distance
travelled by the solvent so I'll show
you how to do that now what we do in is
to the middle point of the dot we are
measuring from the line to the center
part of the dot so that's for this
particular one is three centimeters
three point zero centimeters
I then divide it by the distance moved
by the solvent so where the sole from
this line up to the soles in front so
that one there this is the distance I'm
measuring with my ruler and that is
eight point five centimeters moved by
the solvent so all I need to do next to
find my RF value is ID 3 divided by
eight point five which gives me this
number here I'm going to round it to two
decimal places so my RF value is 0.35
now this value is just a little bit like
I said like a fingerprint so that guy
will always have that RF value now the
really important thing to remember about
RF values is they are always less than 1
so if you found an RF value that has a
number greater than 1 you've probably
just divided the wrong one by the wrong
one so remember if the substance divided
by the solvent substance / solvent we
should always give you naught point
something a number less than 1 so that's
about it so remember chromatography is
about separating inks and or dyes and we
can use it to see what is it in an
unknown compound and this is how to find
an RF value thank you